hello everybody not a typical
episode obviously um
i just wanted to come out here and kind
of address
everything going on with the frenemies
[Music]
um
obviously you know
there's a lot i want to say about it
and a point where
i'll just i'm just gonna start from the
top like first of all i'm gonna say
about trish
like the whole breakup is that like
trish has been saying a lot of things
publicly
which has put me in a tough spot because
on one hand
obviously i want to respect her
you know well-being but at the same time
it's like she's kind of tied my arms
because she's saying a lot of things
publicly
that i feel i need to make some
corrections on
and just you know to speak up for myself
and i want to do this in a way that's
respectful to her because my intention
is not to like burn the bridge or the
blast or anything like that
i just want to give people what i think
is a fair account
of everything that's happened
and so i say with peace and love that
you know as a friend uh
i have come to love and appreciate
trisha
you know as as a partner um
i think she's one of the funniest people
i've ever known one of the most talented
people
you know one of the most dynamic and
entertaining people i've ever known
and so creating frenemies with her is
going to be one of the all-time
highlights for me it's been
such an amazing ride i've learned
and grown from it so much on a personal
level from her
and from you guys the audience obviously
there's a lot of new people
that have come for the show and i feel
like i've become a better person
for this experience and so i want to
make sure that everything i say now
is under the lens of like
appreciation and love for trisha and not
at all trying to burn a bridge
but more just trying to you know defend
myself or correct or set the record
straight in some ways because
you know it's like what trisha she she
she
this is she puts me in these tough
situations where it's like
i'm losing no matter what she can say
whatever she wants
you know what she puts out publicly and
then you know if i just sit and take it
everything's distorted and if i say
anything then i'm the bad guy
for you know
coming after something which is not my
intention at all this
just for the record is not you know uh
so
listen the the the i don't know
what more humanly
i could have done to prevent this from
happening like
i i don't know what humanly
more i could have done i feel like i
have
tried to accommodate her in every
possible
conceivable way you know to make this as
comfortable
as equitable i've been as fair as
possible in terms of like money
creatively and stuff she disagrees with
that so there's some things that
i guess i want to to correct
and you know since we're not doing this
show she's going to put stuff out there
and we're not sitting next to each other
for me to be able to say like well no
this is what actually happened
um now she she keeps going on
about how sh there's creative
differences with her
and the crew that was something she's
she keeps talking about
and so the day after we shot
after we had like broken up we had a
conversation for the first time
ever about her wanting to hire
new staff that she would look for and
hire to work on frenemies
that was the first time we had ever
discussed that
and after talking it out with her i
agreed i said okay we can you know what
again because i just want to make
everything smooth and manageable
we had this big blowout we talked the
evening afterwards i said
you know what let's hire producer you
tell me who you want to hire
and i'll hire him and he can work on
some of the more complex
ideas that you have because she has
ideas like
oh let's do ribbon dancing and it's like
okay well that's a fun idea i agree it's
a cool idea
but like actually executing it finding
the spot
uh filming it the logistics of getting
all the equipment there
everything you know is is is the hard
part that we do
so it's like it's like yeah i have an
idea to go to the moon okay
i mean yeah it's a cool idea but like
you have to figure it out
you know that's the hard part so she
said okay i want a producer i said
you know what it's a good i don't even
hate the idea let's get a producer
who's gonna work with you to to produce
your
ideas i love it
so i agreed you know and i said let's
just
chill out for a few days let things cool
i'm down to hire this producer um
and then you know the next day
without telling me she drops this video
she's quitting for enemies
which took me completely by surprise
and i and i was just you know
i was honestly
i don't know from a business partner
perspective and a friend perspective
that video really rubbed me the wrong
way because i woke up
after having a conversation with her
where i agreed that everything she
wanted to do
and i wake up to her being like saying
all this stuff about
private conversations we had and saying
oh it's the crew's fault uh
it's the people on the crew were unhappy
you know and like
i don't know i just felt like that video
was just so
unnecessary and
i just didn't get it because i had done
everything possible
i want i i didn't get it i was like oh
hi i'm down let's do it
you know in the long stream of things
that i'm willing to do to keep her happy
and it's just
i don't know you know she goes on to on
about how like
we hired sam who's ian's girlfriend
and by the way i explained to her she
said why don't i get to hire people why
are you hiring this new person
i immediately explained to her that
hiring sam had literally nothing to do
with frenemies we have a big production
company we produce a lot of content
sam has been working for us freelance
for months and she recently became
available for full-time employment so i
said this is great i like sam i want her
to be on the team
and i'm gonna hire her as my production
company i said why should trisha have a
say on who i hire for my production
company it's got
it literally has nothing to do with
friends and i explained that to her
but the thing that we discussed you know
that was kind of like a non-starter
is she told me that she wanted a whole
new crew for frenemies because she
didn't feel comfortable with them
she wanted a whole new space she wanted
a whole new crew
um and it just
i don't know it's like she couldn't meet
me halfway i was like yes producer
whole new crew we need to we need to
essentially fire everybody
that's worked on the show from the
beginning
find the new space and change everything
and i don't know for me that's that's
kind of a non-starter because it's like
first of all just on the face value it
doesn't make sense like trisha from the
beginning
we didn't know how long the show was
going to go we put up the money we took
all the risks
for a show that she's already walked out
and quit three times
so she wants me to hire people lease an
industrial space
of which by the way the leases are
usually three plus years on industrial
spaces
for something that she's inevitably
gonna quit
like i mean it's happened three times
already so like and guess who's gonna
take all the risk on that me i'm going
to risk my ass
like i've done this whole process i've
done i've put up the money i've fronted
everything
because i believe in this but now it's
like i don't know i feel like she's
rewriting history a little bit
on on how this came to be but again the
logistics don't make sense i can't go
hire people
and get an industrial space and buy
equipment
for something that's like so uncertain
i mean it doesn't make sense you're
gonna you're just gonna
mess with these people's lives waste all
my time and money
it doesn't make any sense so for me
besides that besides the crew being
extremely capable
extremely hard working they've busted
their asses every week
to put on the best show possible every
sunday night
and the week proceeding we're working
it's the weekend and we're all we're
working on sunday to put the show
together
and so it's it is disrespectful and
demeaning to them to be like
we need to get rid of all of them and
hire new people the people who have
worked their asses off to put this show
to make this show possible
because at the end of the day when me
and trisha don't talk all week
and sunday comes around it's my
responsibility and the crew's
responsibility therefore
to put on a show that's actually going
to work because
it's not my thing to just show up and
not have a plan and so
there's so many weeks where we don't
talk in between the podcasts
and it's falls to me and the crew to
make sure
that there's a show with a plan a
structure
with resources with all everything cited
and prepared for me
you know what i mean everything takes
work nothing is easy you know what i
mean
maybe it looks easy to her like we don't
do anything but everything takes
a lot of work we work a lot
all the time and these guys don't
deserve to be like
we need to fire we i want to fire all of
them and get rid of them
hire a new it's like okay well that's a
non-starter for me
for multiple reasons
and so you know
this is where maybe i [ __ ] up okay is
that i was talking to the crew like
trisha wants to i i was like listen
trisha wants to
hire a new crew i was just being
transparent with them i was like
trisha wants to hire a new crew
obviously that wasn't something i was
going to commit to but i was just like i
don't know what to do about this because
this seems like it's not going to go
anywhere when the when the crew
found out she wanted to fire them all
they were there first of all they've
always been down to go work and do the
shoot
as was scheduled they are good loyal
you know hard-working employees that are
down to get the job done no matter what
i had done a temperature check like how
do you guys feel about going to do this
because there was some there was just
people like you know
the vibe was like trisha wants to fire
you guys and hire new people to do
frenemies
and also do you want to go meet with her
and shoot tomorrow and so obviously
they they were like well it's a little
awkward right
but of course i'm willing to do it
and so i made the executive decision as
their boss
trying to foster a healthy work
environment that let's just not do the
shoot tomorrow bearing everything that's
happened
and take a few days to chill off and so
and the con in the context of that
conversation i think trisha
understandably came to
to make take the meaning like oh they're
on strike
that wasn't the case they were always
down to shoot it and i made the decision
to
not shoot immediately after taking a
temp
check and and after everything that that
happened so
you know and then then another thing
that's like
really unfair is that she keeps saying
things like
one of the employees girlfriends you
know who was hired without my
consent again had nothing to do with you
nothing to do with frenemies
hired for my business uh is the reason
why
you know this is all like falling apart
is because she was offended
that trisha didn't like her
the q and or the the advice segment that
we were planning
first of all i thought it was sam's idea
it was just an idea she pulled from a
document but she did the work preparing
it
i don't think it really matters whose
idea was the fact that trisha was just
going to sit there and trash their work
was kind of unacceptable to me because
ultimately i have to create a safe work
environment for my employees
and it's just kind of toxic to sit there
and [ __ ] on their work whoever did it it
doesn't matter who did it
um but i do want to say for the record
that that's not what happened sam was
not
upset that she didn't like the work um
if anyone was upset it's because she
said
that she wanted to fire everybody and
get a new staff
that made people uncomfortable like okay
well she doesn't even want to be around
me
okay but the thing is she keeps harping
that in all of her videos to the point
where
not only is sam now getting [ __ ] on on
her like social medias people have gone
out of their way and been like you're
the reason frenemies is over
she's people are going to like abs wife
people are going to dan's girlfriend and
just like
random spit firing [ __ ] at them with the
chance that that's the person trisha was
talking about
and that's just it's just not acceptable
you know and this was part of a private
conversation that she made public to try
to justify
why she wanted to leave the show and
that that to me just i don't know
it's just not cool to do that i really
don't like seeing the crew get [ __ ] on
for no reason i have some responsibility
to
take good care like to you know create a
healthy work environment for my
employees and that kind of stuff where
she just taking
private conversations and putting it out
there that's resulting in
like dan's girlfriend being harassed is
just i don't know to me it's
unacceptable and i
i don't know i guess some people
disagree with me on that but
look that's just the way it is i really
don't know what to say
she said that our content was lazy
repetitive
the segment was horrible it doesn't
matter who prepared it it's like
it's just not professional to do that on
air when the crew is there
it's her first day and you know
now i ironically you know sam is a huge
fan of trisha she's the one that like
built the the steamies award for her and
bedazzled it
and made the the little peeps
rolls-royce like sam
loves trisha and um
i just it was just it was just i don't
know it just wasn't cool that she's
gonna [ __ ]
on her work on her first day
and so she she's been a trooper she's
getting [ __ ]
and she was never mad i i think when i
was talking to trisha i said that that
uh
i told her sam's not upset it was just
the whole thing is stupid you guys i
don't i don't know just stop
just stop just stop [ __ ] sending hate
like
they the crew did nothing wrong i
misunderstood the situation i told
trisha
that people were upset that she didn't
like this segment okay i take
the blame for that the reason they were
upset that i misunderstood
is because she said she wanted to fire
them all they were always willing to do
their job
period they have done nothing wrong it's
gotten to the point where i'm i'm just
not speaking my mind anymore i mean the
whole premise of the show
is that we have this openness with each
other
and it's gotten to the point where i'm
processing like oh if i say this
she's gonna walk out which is exactly
what happened you know
but for me it's like okay she can
everything's fair game she can say
anything she want
she called my wife like the c word she
called me
you know she said the most horrible
thing she said i'm a terrible parent
ela's a terrible parent
and for me it's like okay and i
understand again that
she has mental health she has mental
like health issues but
at the end of the day it's just not
i don't feel like it's it's fair even
though she has those issues it's just
i can't be her emotional punching bag
and then
the minute i speak up for myself it
turns into another like show ending
fight it's just
it's just not a fair relationship
um you know i have mental illness
problems too
like that never [ __ ] she doesn't seem to
really give any credence to that like
i have depression i'm medicated for that
[ __ ] 20 milligrams lex for every [ __ ]
day
my dick feels like a piece of wood like
i have no sensation in my penis
side effect and i'm fat by the way also
a side effect
you know i have tourette's by the way
something that she continues to tokenize
which always makes me uncomfortable i
always ask her to stop doing that
insisting that everything i do is oh
that's tourist that's tourette's
i don't like it and i tell her that
every time and she keeps doing it so
like you know
it's just not fair like i'm i i take all
this [ __ ] and she takes no [ __ ]
ever anymore you know even here when she
says like
oh i put out so many ideas
here i said something and i said
something that was lazy or something
like that and he's like well you don't
do anything but i put up
so many ideas for the show and i like
listening like aerial gymnastics like
dancing with the stars like clay pottery
and the thing and i like okay so that
that's the
extent of her involvement she says
here's ideas
and i said great let's go to the [ __ ]
moon after that
it's like an idea is just a fart in the
wind unless you [ __ ]
give it a sniff and internalize it i
don't know if that analogy is good
but it's like you that's that's that's
the fun part
you know let's go to uh
let's go build a habitat on mars
sick how do we get there
you know the tour bus that was
that was very hard to put together i was
very hard to put together
logistically you know
and she she like tore it apart she was
very rude about it saying that
it was unprofessional people didn't know
what they were doing
it was just the cast girlfriend on the
bus this and that it's like yeah it was
the cast
significant others and friends and
family because we because you know how
what's the legal issue of trying to get
a release from random people
i mean we'll put that on in like a
week's time
and i thought it came out great all
things considered and then for her it's
just never good enough like it was [ __ ]
the sound was awful the video was awful
it was super unprofessional it's like
okay
not good enough you know and then here's
another thing
that was like super unfair is that
the night after she posted or that the
day of after she posted her i'm leaving
frenemies
video i texted her trying to be mature
and handle it personally like off
the internet i said you know i just want
to be honest with you
and say i felt it was really unfair how
you put that video out
you know after we worked to try to
resolve this
and she ignores my text and she posts
another 20 minute video
30 minutes later that was in response to
my text
that was more like oh the crews the
reason why this happened and sending
even more hate to their [ __ ]
instagrams
it's just like it's like dude i
i'm not i'm i don't have i i'm a patient
man but i'm not like superhuman
i just was like i'm reaching out to you
to try to resolve this and your response
is to put out another 20 minute video
about the situation
and once again i mean there's an
impossible position where it's like she
can say
and do everything put out all these
videos tweet dm some private messages
and [ __ ]
and i'm just supposed to sit here like a
[ __ ] like gandhi
or siddhartha buddha the buddha the
great buddha
i'm not the great buddha i am fat though
well the buddha was skinny so i don't
even know why where that comes from
you know
[Music]
i don't know dude it's like she kept
pushing me and pushing me it's like i'm
sitting here trying to be an adult and
salvage the situation and she keeps like
pushing the situation in this possible
unsalvageable situation to the point
where and it's like not only that but
now i'm being forced to sit here make a
video that i never wanted to make
in response to all the stuff she put out
there
and it's like imagine how confusing it
is because she goes on the show
and she says oh this questions
is so dumb it's lazy it's crap i hate it
i mean the day before she retweeted it
unprompted
i did not even ask her
i told her about it we went over the
questions she was happy about it
she liked it and retweeted it i didn't
ask her to do that she did that
unprompted
so now all of a sudden it's like this is
the duality of trisha that's just
really
really difficult
we discussed it before we went live i
went over the segment with her
i showed her the questions that people
had and
she liked it she agreed you know it was
a work in progress because we
just posted it and we had only a few
questions to show from because
sam said there was like 2 000 emails to
go through
and it was something people were excited
about the fans were excited about it i
thought it would be fun
and again we went over it before the
episode and she liked it so it's not
like i blindsided her and she was
against it the whole time that's just
not true
she hates the uncle fester costume idea
that we pick all the costumes
and like here's her message about it
when i pitched it to her
you know originally and i'm not look at
i i know this is like a dm
but i do think it's important to
illustrate
the realness of like how
difficult it is to navigate this space
with her because she putting out like
how much she hated the costumes
uh it was my idea she never wanted to do
it she doesn't even know the character
she says i never i don't even know this
character
i sent her this picture i said costume
idea
she says laugh my ass off oh my god oh
my god this is one of my all-time
favorite movies
can we i love her and we said
okay and then trisha went to her
tailor had the costumes made and so how
am i supposed to
about how am i it's like i'm in this
part
she loves it it's one of her favorite
movies and then she hates it
she doesn't even know who the character
is and it's all my idea
and you know [ __ ] me for even making her
do this it's like
i don't understand what am i supposed to
do that's what i mean it's like i can't
humanly do
more she expects super human care
she expects i i'm not a superhuman
you know what i mean i don't have like
psychic abilities
unfortunately i'm working in the
constraints of a mortal mind
this is and then she brings up this five
percent cut thing where it's like
dude it doesn't seem like that much to
ask
that i get a five percent cut to cover
everything that i've spoken about we pay
for the set
we rent the space we film it we use our
equipment we employ the people we edit
it we upload it we post it we get that
sponsors we develop the concepts we work
all week to prep
the segments we pay for the insurance we
do the accounting and the payroll
i send her a fully itemized report every
month
of literally everything and how the
expenses break down and her cut
and the fact that she would even accuse
me of not being transparent is honestly
very hurtful because i've gone so far
out of my way
to be as transparent as possible i show
her literally everything
i have our cpa preparing a monthly
report
itemizing literally everything
we pay for all that we do all of that we
work on sundays to prep the show
and she's complaining that five percent
she's she's she's apparently like i want
to say and how that five percent is
spent
the five percent is already spent on
everything i just said
there's no production company in the
world that would do all that for five
percent
more like fifty percent or even more the
five percent is a family rate it's
literally nothing it's it might not even
be covering our costs to be honest with
you
it's it's it's as close to nothing
as humanly possible and one of the
great efforts i've always made to be as
fair and transparent and accommodating
to trish as possible but it's like she
always keep going back like i have a say
to say what does
what the five percent
how did you hire sam without consulting
me it's like i'm sorry
this is our business she's not just
working on frenemies
why do i need to consult you who i hire
for my business
that seems out it seems outrageous and
then she starts going
i want to itemize breakdown of how that
five percent is spent and i'm like dude
it's not like that
it's a [ __ ] it's just it's a fee it's a
production fee
i'm not giving you itemized deduction of
my of the the entire business that's
just
it's like these absolutely unreasonable
unimaginable
uh bars that i could never reach someone
who
has done everything possible to reach
every bar she set and that's
one she just she keeps setting it higher
and higher to the point where it's like
that is in unhumanly possible to reach
and then she has the the audacity and
i'm just gonna be honest this was she
starts tweeting out
our dms and this is she's just not
acceptable behavior and
listen i know she's like as like like i
appreciate
the mental health concerns that she has
but like there's only so much that i can
tolerate as a result of that
and she starts tweeting out my
our private messages talking about the
show this was a message before the show
ever was made we had not even made one
episode it was all theoretical
i said i think i need 55.45 to cover the
cost of production
and she showed a screenshot of her
saying i'm being jewy by the way
you know
why'd she send why did she post this
why did she post this she posted a
screenshot of herself calling me julie
for wanting five percent to cover the
massiveness
of this production
and again it's like she can say whatever
she wants about my
being jewish she can make all the
stereotypes do everything she want and i
can't ever [ __ ] say [ __ ]
the minute i say anything to her then
it's like shows cancelled you know
it's just not an equitable relationship
and then um and then here's another
thing you know
we bought a whole new studio that we're
in right now she says on one hand she
doesn't come to my house and
she feels uncomfortable so we bought
this studio
she said she doesn't want to come all
the way to downtown l.a or she says she
has trauma about downtown alicia's want
to be or whatever
i'll be honest with you guys she knew
from okay whatever
without being getting into he said she
said i was under the impression that
this was understood that we were going
to be moving to l.a eventually
i mean when we started the podcast it
was in the basement the basement was
always temporary
we bought we owned this building by the
time yeah we already
what yeah it was just because of cover
we were in the basement we had already
owned this building it was
always the plan to move down here but
then she says
i'm not moving i'm not going doing the
show downtown l.a
so she said she starts to get like okay
if you guys don't do it here
you guys need to stay at the house
and so i said you know we had a little
back and forth but ultimately again
trying to appease and do everything
humanly possible
to make this work for trisha we spent 30
thousand dollars
buying all new equipment cameras
switching board
audio equipment microphones
everything uh so that we can continue to
do at the house for her
and she keeps bringing up this like well
you get five percent so you should you
like what is that for you need to be
pain and i say okay you know what let's
keep the show going
let's do it at the house i'm gonna spend
another thirty thousand dollars
on the already fifty thousand dollars i
spent on the set i don't complain about
money i don't give a [ __ ] about it i
really don't
like i can't i don't know dude
and so then we spend all that money on
that [ __ ] and then she's not
she's not comfortable going to the
office and now she's not comfortable
going to the house because the crew's
there
you know the merch issue
is another way that just
is super super sad for me in the same
way
of how she just like wants to cut the
whole crew loose
because first of all we fronted the
money we produced designed
and made in its totality ela did ela
despite trisha saying the meanest and
rudest things about her
knowing that there was a chance that the
show might not work out
you know made the risk used her
company's resources
and and
you know for trisha to just like walk
out i mean we have this merch release
every penny i've made from frenemies by
the way if she wants to talk about money
is tied up in this merch that doesn't
come out for another month
and i don't even know if we're gonna
sell so it's like for all the
complaining she does for money
she's the only one as far as i'm
concerned that's actually making money
from this thing
because i've spent pretty much every
[ __ ] penny i've made from frenemies
into the show
on merch into their own resources buying
more equipment for the [ __ ] studio
paint building the set it's like it's so
easy for her to complain
she shows up she gets a guaranteed check
every [ __ ] month
and i'm spent and i'm putting all the my
money on the line and now i have
hundreds of thousands of dollars tied up
in march
and i'm probably not gonna be able to
[ __ ] sell that my wife worked super
hard on
her staff worked super hard on and now
it's like tough luck dude
trisha got paid and she's complaining
about five percent it blows my mind
up and i'm upset about it i am i can't
hide it i'm just
am it's just not fair it's really not
you know and the release of this is july
8th
we were going to do a we were planning
to do a photo shoot
this thursday something she insisted on
doing
and we put it together with our
resources
we were paying a photographer a uh
product someone to produce it this is
all money that we were paying
upfront out of our pockets and never
even thought to ask her for money
because i don't give a [ __ ] right
in one month's time and she drops the
i'm quitting frenemies video
after me doing everything possible to
resolve this with her privately
so like i the nerve of her to complain
about five percent when i'm literally
not making a [ __ ] penny at this point
it's it's just it's it's just it's just
so disrespectful
it disregards all the hard work we do
not only on the crew but now with my
wife and all the co and all the people
that worked on the merch
it's like okay well you know [ __ ] you
you know
it's just so ironic how she keeps
bringing up money it's like i'm the one
to put my ass online every day
i never bring up money i never complain
about money i never i never ask her to
pay for anything
i'm so open-handed with her i'm so
transparent about everything
and now i'm the one that gets [ __ ]
stiffed with like a
ungodly amount of merch that i have no
idea how i'm gonna sell
but good but you know she gets her
paycheck every every every month
on time clockwork reports
everything
and listen i'm just going to say this
i fully support her skin care products
and everything she brings to the show i
am her number one hype man
i love when she makes money i support
her i want her to do well financially
all the time that's why i'm always
hyping up her only fans her skin care
you know her merch everything because
i'm happy i want her to do well
but it's like you know she came
she promoted her you know skin care
which
again it's a great product i saw it it
works on her so i'm like yeah go buy it
it's top of the link now even on that
our last episode of frenemies
it's the top link there you can go buy
her [ __ ] and god bless her for it
you know but it's like it's easy for her
to quit frenemies after she got this
huge plug for her [ __ ]
and go make a video saying i'm quitting
i'm quitting for enemies with
you know like 10 mid rolls
and then complain about like i want five
percent for production costs
it's just it's like it's just not fair
it's just she she's i don't know what
she wants from me it's just not fair
it's just so it's so not fair
you know
she's got all the security of getting
that check of promoting her [ __ ] and i'm
stuck
with all the [ __ ] bills and five
percent
is like something that she just can't
let go ever
and i'm talking about money something
that i hate doing and i would never want
to talk about
but she keeps bringing it up and now i'm
at this point where i have to talk about
it
because i'm so screwed with the smurf
situation it's like i'm so screwed with
this merch
situation thousands of pieces of [ __ ]
that i don't think anyone's gonna care
about honestly
come next month
and by the way when we sell that [ __ ]
whatever we sell she can get 50 of the
profit
just like i promised her even though she
went on twitter and try to call me a
liar
he's lying i only get 50 it's like
trisha read the message
she shows a message again i don't know
why she's sending
our private messages and okay she outed
me i yes i hit my icon on whatsapp is
metamucil
love that product
she tweets out she circles we are
splitting the 30 percent which is
typically our profit margin it's like
trisha
just read what i wrote to you the profit
margin
is thirty percent i'm giving you half of
the profits
do you want fifty percent of all the
revenue because i will lose money again
apparently you're the only one that's
allowed to make money in this
relationship
i really don't understand
we are splitting to 30 which is
typically our profit margin
that's 50
you know we've been talking about the
merge this was like she was super
gung-ho and passionate about it
like i said we were planning a photo
shoot this thursday that we were we were
already put down like ten thousand
dollars on
and she just you know [ __ ] that right
spent didn't put a penny down on that
[ __ ]
you know and by the way sharing our
business profit margins
is not public information like there's
no reason for her to put out what our
profit margin and that's just not public
information
i just don't understand why she's doing
that you know and then there a whole big
part of her thing was that we don't ask
for her
input on anything that she's like and
that's just
that's just again very upsetting and
very untrue
you guys remember back in the beginning
of the show she was complaining on the
show that i was texting her too much
asking her too many questions and
wanting to involve her too much in the
show
she told me not to bother her you guys
remember that that's in the show
like from the beginning i've tried to
include her and give her as much control
input as she could possibly ever want
and she tells me don't text me so much
it's like okay that's nice for you but
we have
like on sunday night she goes don't text
me past like nine or eight or whatever
it is
it's like nice for you we're all up
preparing for the show so don't [ __ ]
complain
that you don't have control that we
don't care about your input when you're
based literally telling me to [ __ ] off
because you don't want to deal with this
it's like the responsibility has to fall
to someone me
obviously and the crew to put on a
watchable show
so sunday night she's saying don't text
me it's like okay let's do this guys
and then meanwhile she's got the she's
got the hudson to come out here and say
they don't ask me for my input
it's just unwinnable it's unwinnable
situation
i mean we've gone out of our way in
every imaginable way to make her feel
welcome accommodated listen to
appreciate it too
i mean do you and you know
it's just not fair dude i mean like i'm
looking back on like that
the beetlejuice episode on her birthday
and how we went
so far out of our way because we wanted
to it's not like a
i'm not saying that like oh we we wanted
to do this for her to make her feel
loved and appreciated and welcomed
um it's not enough i don't know what it
i just
i don't know it's like an unwinnable
situation
you know i don't want to make this video
at all but like
she keeps putting things out in the
public she's made a bunch of videos a
shitload of tweets
and it's just not fair to me to be able
to just once again sit and take her
her be her punching bag and not even say
anything on behalf of myself or my
employees
you know in the end
the truth is that i'm very grateful for
the experience we've had with frenemies
and all the learning and growing and
developing and
the amazing growth that our channel's
seen as the result of that show
i mean it's been it's been popular and
successful beyond what either of us
anticipated and i have so much
to thank trisha for i mean
and i'm this isn't like i'm not trying
to like cut her out of my life
this is not me trying to say i'm not i'm
i'm not ending things on bad terms with
tricia i mean she's my
family at this point she's marrying my
brother-in-law this is not like
i'm not by any means trying to like cut
her out of my life okay
i cherish her as a friend as a talent as
an entertainer as a comedian
i think i think you know the world of
her in that regard
but you know as a partner
it's just you know
after doing everything possible to make
this work and then being [ __ ] on
the crew and me and the teddy fresh and
disrespected
everybody like as a partner as a
business partner and then putting out
videos and tweets and stuff it's like i
just
i don't know i feel like i owe it to
myself
and to the crew to explain things as i
see them at least
because we're not sitting together to
have this conversation she put out her
side
so you know it's just fair for me to put
out my side i owe it to myself
now and to everybody teddy fresh into
the crew who worked on all this stuff
that's just getting like you know
dropped i do love trisha as a friend
and i do want the best for her and i'm
sure she's gonna bounce back
and do great she's like a freaking you
know phoenix
rice from the ashes always will this is
not me saying like cancel trisha
this is not me saying
anything like that because look we're
all
i don't know i'm not mad at her i don't
blame her i mean i'm this has been a
frustrating experience but like
ultimately i understand who she is and
i'm willing to forgive and forget always
when it comes to her
but there's certain things that are out
in the public domain now that she put
out there that i feel like
you know i need to give my two cents on
so with that being said that's really
all i have to say about this
and um
don't be sad what's the saying don't be
sad it's over just be happy it happened
is that a thing that's the thing right
don't be sad i think shakespeare said
that shout out to your boy
i'm very grateful for the experience for
everybody that's been here
i know it's meant so much to you guys
and for me to be have been a part of
something so meaningful and
such a kind of
big i felt like a kind of like a big
important thing we were a part of and it
was just
like one of the great honors and
memories that i'll always hold
but you know i guess all things have all
good things
end and uh maybe we just you know
don't cry because it's over smile
because it happened
i don't know it is with a heavy heart
you know
that we end the show and
it sucks it does suck but you know what
life goes on right but here's the thing
we're gonna keep making the best content
we can
we are going to keep working our asses
off to keep you know
you guys entertain we're going to be
keeping the content
fun we're going to keep doing our thing
and i hope that you're going to stick
around and join us for the journey
because we're not stopping
we're only getting started and um i'm
sure that trish has got a lot of good
stuff
up her sleeve for you guys as well so
uh and you know worse this is not the
end of ethan and trisha's friendship uh
you know
this is this is just me i'm just
rambling now
thank you guys uh and we'll see on
friday for
after dark